réunion des responsables des radios
libres ce week-end au sénat à paris les
radios libres qui sont dans l'attenté
des décisions du nouveau gouvernement
le commentaire de géra il fallait bien
au moins une victoire de la gauche pour
assister aux assises des deux
fédérations qui représente les petites
radios
les deux frères ennemis se sont mis
d'accord sur un code de bonne conduite
concernant la puissance le statut et la
publicité
selon ce code les radios devront être
constituées sous forme d'association à
but non lucratif et dans ce petit monde
des radios libres
on a surtout demandé l'arrêt du
brouillage celle assises nationales des
radios libres lance un appel qui est le
suivant la cessation immédiate de toutes
formes de brouillage contre les radios
libres sans ce nom que la fédération
nationale et rod libre lance cet appel à
toutes les structures sociales
politiques associations et autres pour
qu'elle reprenne en charge des appels
pour la liberté d'expression sur les
ondes pour le moment le brouillage
persiste pour la grande majorité des
radios
ce qui n'empêche pas les projets
d'installation de croître rien que sur
paris on en compte actuellement plus de
40 ans mais j'entends les autres aussi
c'est normal l'apparition des radios
locales pose un problème nouveau c'est
celui de la gestion d'une liberté d'un
droit qui a été jusqu'à présent méconnu
à nous réprimer beaucoup au cours de ces
dernières années
un des problèmes de cette gestion c'est
celui du financement de ces radios
locales et parmi les problèmes de
financement c'est celui de la publicité
et du financement publicitaire or il va
falloir que très rapidement nous
puissions inventer
une façon de bénéficier des recettes
publicitaires de façon à ce qu'elles
permettent de financer un véritable
service public des radios locales
beaucoup de question reste donc posée
d'autant que le gouvernement pour le
moment se contente de consulter il n'a
pas la moindre envie de laisser la plus
petite porte ouverte à une situation et
l'italienne